It's been a long time.
Let's not ever be apart
this long forever, okay?
(AUDIENCE CHEERS)
And of course, right on cue,
always when we come back,
big news.
Dianne Feinstein,
our senator for s-- (LAUGHS)
No. Don't laugh.
No, she was a great
serving senator here.
Died today.
First female mayor
of San Francisco,
and everyone there today
observed a minute
of no shoplifting.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
'Cause...
Let me tell you,
when she was mayor
of San Francisco,
she had that city under control.
When there was poop
in the street,
it was because John Waters
was making a movie.
(LAUGHTER)
Also a senator for 31 years,
in politics for 54 years.
Not once was she caught on tape
giving a hand job at a musical.
(LAUGHTER)
I think that has to count.
-(CHEERING)
-Oh, you saw.
You've seen Lauren Boebert.
She's the MAGA congressman.
I guess she's
a 36-year-old grandmother.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
She is from Colorado,
a "family values" Republican.
Was caught on tape.
She was at Beetlejuice, like,
getting her tit grabbed,
vaping, grabbing cock.
(LAUGHTER)
I'm not making this up.
This is your government at work.
(LAUGHTER)
And...
So they threw her
out of the theater,
and on the way out,
she gave them the finger
and said,
"Do you know who I am?"
(LAUGHTER)
Now, see, this is the difference
between Republicans
and Democrats.
When Biden says that,
he's genuinely asking.
(LAUGHTER)
But okay, good news and bad news
about our government.
(SIGHS) There's going to be
a government shutdown again.
What the-- Why do we always
go through this?
I know it's terrible
for a lot of people.
On the bright side, the Senate
approved a dress code...
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
...solving a problem
they created last week.
Really.
Although it's just for the men.
Kyrsten Sinema,
you're familiar with her.
She retains the right
to dress like Kate McKinnon
as Weird Barbie.
(LAUGHTER)
And... (CHUCKLES) ...there was
a Republican debate this week.
Ron DeSantis is here.
He was on it.
Apparently he won it,
according to the polls.
But it was a shit show.
Was it not?
Did you see this?
I couldn't get through it.
I mean, they were just
talking over each other.
It made me so tense,
I had to calm down
by watching a video
of Britney Spears
dancing with knives.
(LAUGHTER)
I...
This thing was--
I-- I always play
the Republican debate
drinking game.
That's where you take a drink
every time you go,
"Oh, God, I need a drink."
(LAUGHTER)